it's the Year 1325 at the Balinese and
modernise armies are about to square off
at what has been called one of the
bloodiest medieval battles in Italy but
also one of the dumbest because this was
the War of the bucket to understand why
the war started we have to look at the
political climate it started in and for
dad we'll have to go back all the way to
800 cee with the crowning of the First
Holy Roman Emperor Charlemagne by the
Bishop of Rome and even though chowmein
didn't realize it back then his crowning
by the Bishop of Rome set into motion
the centuries-long struggle between the
European kingdoms and the church
especially as it pertains to the Holy
Roman Empire how did this happen well
first thing you have to understand is
that the Bishop of Rome is the Pope and
chowmein was the one who appointed the
Bishop of Rome who was then the one who
crowned chowmein as the Holy Roman
Emperor which created a weird circular
division of who actually had power over
whom on top of that Chairman's
appointment of the Pope said the
president of European Kings appointing
their own bishops and other church
officials in their own lands because if
a king can appoint a bishop of Rome why
can't he did appoint any other bishop
however chalahe main also said the
president of the Pope crowning the Holy
Roman Emperor so if you were the ruler
who controlled the appointment of the
Bishop of Rome you were also the one who
controlled the crowning of the Holy
Roman Emperor in theory anyways this
resulted in the fact that after chowmein
determining in northern Italian lands
that became the continuation of the Holy
Roman Empire turned into a political
battleground over the control of the
papal succession with oftentimes the
ones who controlled it being
unsurprisingly also the king of the
Germans and the Holy Roman emperors but
I'll dissipate the see actively started
to reform the appointment of the Bishop
of Rome and diminished inabilities
control over them and when Henri de 4th
became a six year old king of the
Germans he clearly didn't have enough
experience at the time to handle the
delegated relationship between the king
and the Pope so the church council in
Rome seized on the opportunity and
restructured the rules of the papal
succession creating the College of
Cardinals as the sole body fit to
appoint the Pope this meant that no
longer could a ruler control the
appointment of the Pope at least to such
an
as they did up until now this created
many problems within Europe although I'm
going to be focusing on just the Holy
Roman Empire for one Henry the fourth
now no longer a kid denounced the
current Pope Gregory the seventh as
illegitimate since he wasn't appointed
by any King the Pope on the other hand
announced Henry the fourth for being an
illegitimate ruler of the Holy Roman
Empire since he wasn't officially count
by the Pope on top of that even though
the Bishop of Rome wasn't appointed by
the nobility anymore all the other
bishops and church officials around
Europe still wear which meant that they
were more loyal to their feudal lord
than the church the Pope tried to remedy
this through several dubious power
grabbing moves of using the tradition of
investitures to control the appointment
of church officials this resulted in a
lot of political intrigue and
instability throughout Europe and even a
fifty-year-old civil war in Germany as
the factions led to the nobility and the
Pope fought over who had the rights of
appointing church officials it ended in
1122 with an agreement called the
Concordat of worms where the nobility
could retain some of its control over
the appointment of church officials but
the Pope was finally recognized as
having some power in the actual
appointment process and even though this
treaty settled certain problems it
resulted in the fact that now you had
two opposing factions roughly on equal
footing meaning that throughout most of
the Middle Ages there was lots of
continuous political maneuvering
intrigue and battles between the
supporters of the church and the state
and as it pertains to the Italian part
of the Holy Roman Empire these divisions
played a vital part in the political
landscape of the various Italian
city-states this is because the area was
kind of a proxy battleground between the
Holy Roman Empire and the papacy it
properly started off 45 years after the
Concordat of worms in 1167 with the
foundation of the Lombard League this
league was a coalition of various
Italian city-states that didn't like the
fact that the Holy Roman Emperor
declared direct Imperial control over
them and surprise surprise the league
was supported by the papacy the Holy
Roman Emperor Friedrich the first led an
army to Italy but was defeated by the
Lombard League at the Battle of like
nan-oh and had to sue for peace
several years later this peace treaty
recognized the Holy Roman Emperor as the
ruler of northern Italian city-states
but it also gave Italian cities a lot of
autonomy which
proved problematic this is because after
gaining all this autonomy many in fact
all Italian city-states start to have a
big rivalry amongst each other and this
political environment proved to be
perfect for the next stage of the church
versus the Holy Roman Empire power
struggle with cities inter starting to
be loyal to the church party called the
goofs or the Imperial party called the
Ghibellines how are these divisions
developed their own little weird
dynamics outside of the overarching
church versus thre plot cities would
sometimes not even care what each party
stood for and chose their allegiances
according to what was the most
politically and economically beneficial
to them for example the church party
tended to be more prominent in large
mercantile cities as the Emperor was the
main threat to their wealth and trade
networks on the other hand the imperial
party tend to be more prominent in
smaller cities and the countryside that
oftentimes felt threatened by the bigger
mercantile cities on top of that even
though some cities were starched
procharged party or pro imperial party
other cities didn't mind switching their
allegiances of it suited them plus some
cities had bickering imperial and church
factions that would oftentimes fight
against each other over the control of
the city and even though it was the
power struggle between the Holy Roman
Emperor and the Pope that started these
parties northern Italian city-states
took it up a notch your allegiance to
one or the other party started to affect
many other things outside of just your
pro church or pro Empire leanings any
big and small issues or disagreements
started to be split amongst party lines
and not just that depending on what
party you were associated with it
affected what taverns and shops you were
allowed into what cities he could trade
in how you dressed and what side you put
the feather on your head on and it even
affected how you cut certain fruits the
allegiances of some cities to its party
became so strong that you can tell what
party a city supported by just looking
at its coat of arms today if it has a
white cross on a red field it supported
the imperial party if it has a red cross
on a white field it supported the church
party these divisions came to a boiling
point during the 13th century
interregnum of the Holy Roman Empire
this was a sixty-seven years long
succession crisis within the Holy Roman
Empire where the princes were unable to
agree on a new king this instability
combined with the very
Pretender kings and the continuous power
struggle between the Holy Roman Empire
and the papacy was the final straw for
northern Italy and even though there are
battles between the Imperial and church
factions prior to the interregnum the
interactive period took it into an
overtime
[Applause]
the Imperial versus the church faction
struggle took a bit of a respite after
the 1289 church party win at the Battle
of Camp aldino this battle drastically
diminished the power and consequently
the thread of the impale party in Italy
and because Florence was the one leading
the church faction in this battle they
became a prominent if not the main power
within the party but now since the
church party seemingly won with the
imperial party being on its back foot
the Florentine church faction ironically
started to be concerned with the
increased papal influence within the
city so a split within the church
faction happened with the supporters for
more papal control being called black
glyphs and the supporters for less papal
control being called white glyphs the
black church party with the support of
the Pope eventually won and most of the
white church party members were exiled
from the city which included the famous
Dante who after his exile went on to
write the dentist at Ferno but I digress
even though this church party division
was most prominent in Florence it showed
the underlying problems and disunity
within the faction and the imperial
party wasn't any better with Emperor
Henry the seventh stating that he was
disgusted by both sides actions pointing
out how some members trade very far from
the initial party goals this was because
at this point the church and Imperial
parties meant much more and many other
things to many other people than just
the power struggle between the church
and the Holy Roman Empire plus if you
think about it it isn't that big of a
stretch that after so much fighting
through multiple generations the reasons
for once loyalty to their party became
skewed to say the least so at the start
of the 14th century the prelude to the
war of the bucket was a multiple
centuries long power struggle between
the church and the Holy Roman Empire
that turned so out of hand and created
so many fields in northern Italy that
now even the Pope and the Emperor
denounced some of the acts committed by
both factions hope you enjoyed the video
to be honest the whole church versus
Empire factions of medieval Italy is a
subject so complex many of dissertations
have been written on it and therefore I
had to skip or simplify a lot of nuances
or details that shape certain normal
arching decisions
thus there's a lot of footnotes in the
description that are trying to explain
some of it and if you want to know more
are always sources in my scripts lastly
if you're looking forward to the War of
the bucket video that will be coming out
of my channel at some point consider
subscribing and maybe hitting that Bell
icon because the truth is the War of the
bucket actually did not happen as
portrayed in all of these YouTube videos
[Music]